BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hello.
My name is Bruno Oliveira, and
welcome to our third episode
in the Play Games
and the NDK series.
We're going to talk about some
threading and lifecycle issues
that may be tricky.
So first of all, let's
start with threading.
So when you are using
Play Games and NDK, what
you have to realize,
all the time,
is that the UI thread is
different from your game
thread.
So whenever you're
writing your game logic,
that's going to be
running on the game
thread on the native side.
And when ever you do most of the
calls with he Play Games API,
you're going to want to
do them from the UI thread
on the Java side.
So usually, one of
the patterns that you
can use to manage the
difficulty is just
create methods called post
something something and then
those methods post
to the UI thread.
And then on the UI
thread, you actually
use the game helper to make
the corresponding API call.
So something like
this, post submit
score, which we covered
on the last video,
you just call that
from the native side
and then that posts
to the UI thread.
How do you call this
from the native side?
Well, you can just
use J and I. But now,
how do you actually
do the opposite?
How do you call from
dalvik to native?
When you call from dalvik to
native, all you have to do
is declare native
method in your class,
and then implement the
corresponding native method.
So for instance, here we are
reporting that the sign in
has succeeded into
the native code.
When you write
the native method,
one thing that you
have to look out for
is that you're actually
running on the UI thread.
Even though you've
crossed the native barrier
into native code,
that doesn't mean
that you're running
on the game thread.
You're actually running
on the UI thread,
and if you start trying to
manipulate your game objects
and game logic
there, you might run
into very hard to debug issues.
So one of things you can do is
just synchronize at that point.
However, synchronization
may be expensive.
Like if you have a
mutex or a semaphore
and so on, you're going
to log that on every frame
that your game is
going to draw, you
might end up with
a very slow game.
So one of the very useful
patterns we usually see,
is you want to do
an atomic write,
especially when it's a very
small data structure that you
just want to like pass a
Boolean between threads,
you can do just
an anatomic write.
So in this case, we are using
the system dot atomic dot h.
So these are a few
convenience functions
that allow you to do
atomic writes and reads.
In this case, we are getting
the new state from the UI thread
and then writing it atomically
to that static variable called
state.
Because this means that when you
try to read it from your game
thread, you can just
read it because this
is going to be called
for any threat.
You can just read it, because
since writing it is atomic,
you don't have to worry about
various conditions there.
So you get the state
there based on that.
So this means you can actually
get the state on every frame,
so you don't have to have a
callback saying yes, anything
has succeeded or failed
on the native side.
Because, in any
event, you're going
to have to process every frame
to do animations and such.
So you're already occupying
the CPU on every frame,
so it doesn't really cost much
more just to read a Boolean
variable to see if the
user is signed in or not.
So it can eliminate some
complications there that way.
So it can call a gets an
in state on every frame
however, without having to
write callbacks or anything.
So let's talk about the
lifecycle of a Play Games app.
So back in the good old days,
I remember that writing a game
was pretty easy because
there was no lifecycle.
Essentially the game got
started, the game got played,
and then the user
stopped the game,
and it goes back to
the operating system.
So that was a pretty easy time.
Now, with modern
operating systems,
especially on
mobile devices, you
have a whole bunch
of callbacks that you
have to pay attention to.
So when you're game
starts, you get onCreate
and then you get onStart
and then you get onResume
and then you get
the WindowFocus,
and then you get onPause.
And then you lose
the window focus
because of the lock
screen, and then you
get onStop because the user has
gone back to the home screen.
And then you get
onStart again, so it's
a whole bunch of callbacks.
Some of them are hierarchical,
some of them are not.
Some of them come out of phase,
and you have to pay addition
to all of those callbacks to
know when you can and when you
cannot render stuff
into your game.
Because sometimes you may
even have a GL surface,
sometimes you don't
have a GL surface.
Sometimes you should
not be running.
deallocate stuff.
So you have to pay attention
to all those callbacks.
So it's important to keep track
in your native game of where
in the lifecycle you are
regarding those callbacks.
You have to know
whether or not you
are between onResume
and onPause.
You have to know whether or
not you have the window focus.
You have to know whether
or not you have a surface
or you don't have a surface,
and so on and so forth.
And now, we're going to talk
about how to integrate Play
Games into that flow because
it's very important as well,
if you're using Play Games to
know when you can make Play
Games API calls and
when you cannot.
So let's try to simplify
this lifecycle a little bit.
It's not as scary as it looks.
So normally, this is a basic
Android activity lifecycle.
You get onCreate
and you get onStart
and then you get
onResume and onPause.
These events are all
nested within each other,
so your only going to get
onResume only after onStart.
And then before you get onStop,
you're going to get onPause.
So you can have a
variable that tracks
where in that state
machine you are.
And then, of course, you're game
should only be actively playing
between onResume and onStart.
And then, of course, there is
an out of phase state machine,
which is the window
focus, so we know
focus can come in and come
out even if it's out of phase
with the other events.
So you should not
assume that's going
to happened between
onResume and onPause,
but you should assume
that that may happen out
of phase with that.
So you have to keep track of
when you have the window focus.
Other than that, if you're using
OpenGL, and you most likely
are if you're
using NDK, you also
have to keep track of when
the surface gets created,
gets resized and gets destroyed.
So that's one more piece--
one more moving piece
that you have to keep track of.
So it's only when you have
those five things that you
can actually do
active game play.
So you have a surface,
you have focus,
and the activity is
in its resumed state.
So how does the Play
Games API merge into this?
So this is where we have
the game play, right?
So how do you deal
with the Play Games API
lifecycle on top of that?
So fortunately, the
Play Games lifecycle
is actually nested in
the activities lifecycle,
so it's not actually as
difficult as you might imagine.
So you have onStart
and onStop, so
between onStart
and onStop that's
when the Play Games activity
lifecycle actually happens.
Typically, after
onStart-- so there's
no way to keep a
connection to Play Games
while your application
is not started.
So whenever you get
onStop, you actually
lose the connection
to Play Games and have
to restore it on onStart.
If you're using Game Helper
or basic Game Activity,
that restoration is done
for you automatically.
So you don't have
to worry about that,
but you have to
know that it exists.
So whenever you get
the onStart callback,
you're not connected
to Play Games.
And then you have to wait
for the onSignInSucceeded or
onSignInFailed callback.
So there is this window
of time between onStart
and onSignInSucceeded where
your activity is started,
it may even be resumed
or have window focus,
you may even have
the GL service,
but you might not be connected
to Play Games because you're
waiting for the
onSignInSucceeded or
onSignInFailed
callbacks to be called.
Only after that point are
you actually connected
to Play Games, and you
can make API calls.
And remember that
when you get onStop,
you get disconnected
from Play Games.
So this is what the
lifecycle looks like.
So to simplify
this a little bit.
So what happens-- what
may go wrong in this case?
So suppose that your
game is actually running,
and then before you get the
onSignInSucceeded callback,
you try to unlock something,
you achieve something
very extraordinary and
you want to unlock it,
and then you might
run into trouble.
Because at that point
in the lifecycle,
the Play Games API is
not accepting API calls.
So if you haven't
thought about that,
you're going to get a crash.
And if you have
thought about that
and you're perfecting it with
an is connected test, what's
going to happen is
that achievement
is going to be lost.
So nobody wants that.
So one of the strategies
that some games use
is that when you are between
onStart and onSignInSucceeded,
you show a please wait screen.
This is usually not so
bad because the interval
of time between onStart
and onSignInSucceeded
is usually small.
If the user has already
signed in before,
it's going to be pretty small.
If the user has never
signed in before,
it's also going
to be pretty small
because it's going
to fail quickly.
So it's going to
be very-- it's not
going to be typical for that to
take more than say one or two
seconds.
So it's probably a good
idea to put a please wait
screen between onStart
and onSignInSucceeded.
Or of course, just handle that
within the logic of your game.
So for instance, if
every level starts
with this intro screen that's
going to last five seconds,
then you don't need to
put up a wait screen
because you know that
SignInSucceeded is going
to happen before
that pop-up-- I mean
before that story
board scene goes away.
But it's nice to
check for that anyway.
Once that please
wait screen goes way,
you know you can
safely do API calls.
So that's when you try
to unlock something.
So this is one of the very
useful patterns in that sense.
So the actual implementation
is, of course, up to your game.
You can do something very smart,
or you can do something much
more simplistic, something
just like putting a please wait
screen, but the important thing
is to notice that you have this
lifecycle issue, and you should
be attentive in order not
to make any API calls
when you shouldn't.
And I guess that's pretty much
all there is to the lifecycle.
Thank you very
much for watching,
and we hope you
make great games.